hello everyone and welcome back to the
world blitz championship it's one of
those games that we absolutely must show
it's Hikaru Nakamura the speed demon and
the highest-rated blitz player in the
world some of you might not know this
he's a high rated even than Magnus
Carlsen faces holidays of Ferrara and
the both of them did extremely well in
the rapid section here our won third
place for Roger won second place and now
they face face off against each other in
the round three of the world blitz
championship so without further ado
let's check it out we're not going to
overanalyze it since it's a blitz game
let's just enjoy it with efore by
Nakamura and c5 algirdas that goes for
the Sicilian defense we have Knight to
f3 d6 Knights the c3 and Knight to f6
we have h3 by Hikaru nice to see six and
d4 now finally striking in the center C
captures Knight captures and E 5 pushing
he carves Knight back Knight back to f3
and Bishop to e7 preparing to castle we
have Bishop to c4 Hikaru does the same
with castles by Allah days our castles
by Hikaru and now Bishop to e6
countering the light square bishop here
and there should be back to b3
we have h6 making some room for the King
also taking away the g5 square from
White's pieces and rook to e1 now
continuing development and mountain ice
to a5 going for Hikaru strong light
square bishop now well white can't
capture on e6 this only helps black
because after F captures it improves his
center and improves his chances of
executing d5 early on so Bishop to e3
this position has been reached before I
was reached in last year's Russian rapid
championship by Alexander Alexia versus
another baton and in that game Queen to
d3 was played but here blush of the e3
is a new move so as of move 12 we have a
completely new game we have a 6 a 7
point will no longer be a target so you
can activate your rook we have Quinta e
2 and now Queen to c7
we have rook a to D 1 and now Alvarez
decides it's time to eliminate one of
the defenders of the d5 square Knight
captures we have C cap
son b3i usually you'd want to capture
towards the center but here I think he
karo
prefers to keep his C file available for
his rooks so we have b5 preparing to
dislodge the knife would be for so
Hikaru does it himself and Quint the b7
now putting pressure on the e4 pawn now
with Knight to the tomb Nakamura defends
it and rook a to c8 now with a three and
now as the position allows it
Ferrara pushes d5 with it captures a
nightcap force on B 5 and now pinning
the night with Queen to f3 you cannot
move it otherwise you're gonna lose the
Queen so Queen to c6 early race and now
puts the Queen to a defender square
where the rug defends it Knight captures
on d5 Bishop captures and the Queen to
g3 now now a very attacking square for
the Queen but ali reza finds a brilliant
move which is f5 it threatens f4 r to
just you know win material and offers
the e5 pawn so why does he offer d5 pawn
well it's only a temporary pawn offer
because he karo captures it there is no
better move now Bishop to d6 and the
bishop pair is now fully operational we
have Queen back to c3 and now the g2
point is up for grabs
so first Bishop captures and g2 you
could also go for Bishop to h2 check
which is which is quite exciting then
you allow this Queen to g6 with the idea
of checkmating the White King but in a
bullets game that's well no one would
would be able to calculate that because
after we move the Queen and there's also
an attack from the rook to the Queen
really exciting stuff but Allah days ago
is for Bishop cat person g2 first
offers a queen trade now we have Queen
captures Bishop back captures and c6 and
now Bishop to c5 sorry Bishop to c5
offering a trade of course ali reza has
the bishop pair and he has no interest
in in allowing the he car to under his
bones here so rook to f6 with ideas of
rook to g6 check Hikaru moves the King
King to f1 and now Bishop f4
avoiding the Queen trade are avoiding
the Bishop trade and keep
the bishop pair Bishop to e3 offering
the trade again Bishop to h2 and rook
the c1 now we have looked the g6 by
Levesque and here you have to be really
careful a lot of danger lurking in the
position for example if he Carl plates
on the life let's say Knight b3 you want
to get your knife to a more active
square all that is I can even offer a
full rook with Bishop to f3 even give it
up with check for example after King h7
there's no defense against rook to g1
mate the bishop on f3 is just that
powerful so he karo of course realizes
this he pushes place King to e2 and the
now rook to d8 avoiding further trades
gets the rook to another open file
Knight to f3 by Hikaru and now but
should be back to b8 again keeping the
bishop safe
we broke the g1 and here finally a
little ali reza decides to trade as he
was extremely low on time here otherwise
as his position is better white King his
wide open I'm sure he would have moved
the rook and well rigor some f4 action
and just kept the tension but he's very
long one time rook captures rook
captures and the King to f7 now starts
to bring the King into the game and also
there was just the threat of Bishop
captures here since the Jeep on his
pinned so King f7 and now Knight to d4
again threatening one of the bishops
rushing back to d7 guarding f5 with f4
not allowing any f4 ideas from ali reza
in the future and now look back to ea8
pinning the bishop now this is again a
threat so unpinning king f2 and now rook
to e4 a nice central lights where as a
Nakamura does not have a light square
Bishop
so knight back to e to deafen India for
pawn twice now and Bishop to e6
preparing at to stick this bishop over
to c4 we have looked back to d1 and now
g5 with King to f3 adding a third
defender to the f4 pawn G captures
Knight captures and here again if
otherwise I had more time he most likely
would have kept the bishop pair but here
he didn't find anything better
he played Bishop captures on f4 Bishop
captures and now h5 so all in all the
material on the board is equal
Nakamura has a double beep on where as
ali reza has a past past f-pawn and the
f1 queens on a light square which is
great since the bishop from c4 is able
to guard the light square something to
take into consideration where went you
know deciding to trade and give up your
bishop pair and go for this endgame so
rook to d6 by Nakamura goes after the
pawn but now rook the c4 now going out
after these guys here we have h4 and now
comes Luke the c2 with Bishop to e5 by
Nakamura now defending the B to pawn and
rook the c4 now going after the dh44
so rook captures an a6 with rook
captures an h4 and now rook the a7 with
check with King to e8 as the bishop
nicely covers the D squares and Bishop
to f6 now attacking a lyricist rook but
now Bishop to d5 check King to e2 and
now rook to e4 with check King to d3 and
here Bishop to c4 with Church so ali
reza was able to set up this whole thing
I put the bishop to be guarded by the
pawn here the bishop now guards the
queening squared the rook prevents the
King from helping out King to c3 and
here Nakamura has to play something like
Bishop to b4 to keep an eye on the f2
square but Nakamura played beasts every
first yeah sorry oh it is a pushed f4
and here Nakamura should play Bishop to
d4 but he played b3 first now feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
winning move for ali reza while i give
you a couple of seconds so for those we
were able to do it congratulations on
figuring out that you have a task pawn
and you should definitely push it and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
it show ignored the bishop just push f3
and it is of course winning now you
don't have time to block with Bishop to
d4 which i mentioned that was crucial
til he carves defense because after
Bishop to d4 you just capture it and
after King captures you just continue
pushing the pawn there's no way for the
rook to help out with the defense of the
pawn pushing so after I have three
Nakamura there is nothing to do
capturing the bishops
stuff played Bishop to g7 with ideas of
rookie check and rook to f8 but it's
pointless since the the D F 1 square is
the light square and is guarded by the
light square bishop with f2 and now rook
to AAA to check King to d7 and it was in
this position that he Cara Nakamura
resigned the game and a remarkable
victory for young all areas of Raja who
is now on on three out of three in the
blade section not only that he takes
down the highest rated best player in
the world Hikaru Nakamura the the
so-called speed demon so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoy that Magnus is
also on three out of three so we could
expect the two of them to face each
other fairly quickly which will be a
treat for everyone so let's let's just
enjoy that if it happens so I would like
to thank Dali but yeah coming for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous video serum
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the world
blitz championship not analysing too
much just enjoying it so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your Sunday